Adam 22 Adam calls me a misogynist you
guys remember this beef I had with Adam
me and Adam were fine I enjoyed going on
his show and then he this summer decides
to call me a misogynist now I take this
allegation very seriously this is very
serious stuff and I don't take that
lightly he also continued to talk about
how I I I fell off I guess I guess I'm
just falling off and really all of these
guests come on his show to talk
about me so
Adam this is just me pointing out that
the real
misogyny is having your wife sleep with
five men now Adam 22 loaned his wife out
to another man so he had his wife of
like three months do a porno with
another man right after they got married
so let of the plug SLP with Jason love
and they did a a porno together and
really guys um I think this is an insult
to the institution of marriage I don't
understand why people like this get
married marriage is supposed to be a
religious institution I'm a Catholic and
in the Catholic church we believe it's
till death do you part for richer for
poor for sickness and in health till
death do you part and people like this
make a mockery of the sacrament of
marriage
now Adam 22 has um really insulted me
many times on the internet and his most
recent insult you know I I half
kiddingly asked if his wife wanted to
box me you know because I I went I went
boxing in Miami I was like I did my
first time and I just thought it was
funny and he says that he is going to
box me because apparently I am trans I
didn't know my whole life I didn't know
I was trans I I didn't I never been told
that I looked like a man before I came
on the internet but
apparently I am just super manly and I
am just a trans apparently you know so
um that's a bit rude that's a bit rude
but you know whatever whatever so
recently he decided to release a photo
of his wife Lena with five men behind
him let's pull it
up oh my
gosh one guy wasn't
enough now we're going to do not one not
two not three not four but five men I
think this is very sad I think it's very
sad I think it's sad because one day
again uh Pearl cares about the kids here
if you guys wanted to just be in a
relationship and do this craziness
that's fine that's on you but I think
that children have right and I think it
is your responsibility as a parent to
not do things that would make it
difficult for your kid to grow up and I
don't know why they keep engaging in
behavior that one day their kid is going
to have to grow up and see I think it's
wrong and I think it's selfish so
Twitter has had a lot to say about this
now Ryan says bring the camera guy for
your wife's Five Guy meal is insane yes
this is crazy why did you guys have to
get married just be in a relationship
and don't make the kids suffer yes guys
that is making the kids suffer so I
tweeted it is the end of times yes yes I
do think this is the end of times you
know and I will say Adam is a marketing
genius I am sure they are making a
ton off of this now but at what cost is
this worth the price that you pay I mean
your kids's mental health oh whatever I
guess I guess they'll be fine and you
know what we have had an entire
generation of people that said their
kids will be fine my kid will be fine in
a single mother home my kid will be fine
without their dad around my kid
will be fine with me working as a
stripper my kid will be fine with me
working and not being at home and the
truth of the matter is these kids are
not fine we have more mental health
issues in America than we have ever had
in all of history we have kids wake up
and just decide to shoot up a school and
a lot of these issues are linked to a
breakdown in the family unit with
parents that really were were just
selfish where they thought oh
I my my money is more important my
feelings are more important and my
career is more important and really
they're trading their kids mental health
for what a little bit of money a little
bit of gold